네. 안녕하세요. 여기 어디 사업?
오늘은 성수동에 와 있습니다. 지금
뒤에 보이는이 건물을 촬영할 예정인데
지금 좌측으로는 서울숲이 있고 그리고
우측으로는 서아리 아파트가 있습니다.
그리고 이쪽 편에는 서울숲 복합문화
체육 센터가 있는데이 건물의 위치가
굉장히 좋습니다. 그리고 지금 보시면
알겠지만 건물이 굉장히 높아요.
중공업 지역에 위치하고 있어서
상부층부터는 뷰가 굉장히 좋을 것으로
어 생각이 됩니다. 제가 한번 직접
들어가서 어떻게 설계를 하고 어떻게
공간을 만들었는지서 한번 물어보도록
하겠습니다. 가시죠.
[음악]
네, 안녕하세요.
>> 네, 안녕하세요.
>> 지금 여기 땅은 사실 여기 골목 안에
들어와 있긴 한데 땅은 혹시 어떻게
하게 되셨어요?
>> 네, 제가 20년 사업을 하면서 사을
하나 갖고 싶다는 로망이 좀
있었고요.
>> 아,
>> 계속 뭐 수년 전부터 도전을 했는데
마음을 먹어도 계약까지 이어지는
경우가 쉽지가 않더라고요.
>> 그러다가 제 친구 중에 부동산 법인을
하는 친구가 있어서 우연히이 땅을
소개해 줬고 그때는 사실이 땅이
두필집입니다.
>> 아. 그중에 한 필지만 소개를 해줬던
건데 현재 66평 정도 되고요.
처음에 제가 매입한 거는
34평이었습니다.
>> 66평 치고는 건물이 진짜 굉장히 커
보이거든요. 지금 옆면적은 한 몇 평
정도 돼요?
>> 옆면적은
200평 이상 됩니다. 공사하기도 좀
쉽지 않았을 것 같은데 공사는 좀
어떠셨어요?
>> 네. 시간이 꽤 많이 걸렸고요. 어,
토지 매입부터 저희가 입주는 날까지
한 3년 반 정도 걸렸던 거 같아요.
그리고 설계를 처음에 간단하게 했다가
제가 사실 디자이너 출신이거든요.
그래서 마음에 안 드는 거예요.
그래서 설계를 잘하시는 분을 다시
찾아서 다시 재설계를 했었고 허가
과정도 굉장히 길었어요. 설계 허가만
한 1년 이상 걸렸었고 건축도 1년
이상 걸렸습니다.
>> 그러니까 진짜 기간이 진짜 오래 걸린
거 같아요.
>> 네. 꽤 긴 시간이었고 많이
힘들었습니다. 네. 아, 사업 그
매입하시고 나서 좀 어떠셨어요?
>> 처음에는 사실은 뭐 건축에 대해서
전혀 잘 몰랐기 때문에
>> 1층 2층짜리 단층 주택이었거든요.
그래서 리모델링을 해서 사용할까
하다가 여러 가지로 고민을 해 보니
>> 여기는 용적률도 400%까지 나오고
건축을 하면 더 효율이 좋아지겠다라는
판단을 했었습니다. 그래서 건축을
결심하게 됐었고요. 언전 부동산
초보, 건축 초보가 유튜브로 동기
부여해서
>> 아, 그렇죠.
>> 네. 하게 된 게입니다.
>> 사업 내부가 좀 궁금한데 한번 직접
가서 한번 좀 보도록 하시죠.
>> 네. 내려가 보시죠.
>> 네.
>> 여기는 살롱대 엑사라고 저희 피팅
쌀롱입니다. 저희가이 비즈니스를
한국에서 20년 가까이 했고요.
신경을 이번에 좀 많이 썼습니다.
사담이지만 옆에 건축주가 사실
우리나라에서 가장 좀 인테리어 잘하는
업체예요. 거기 대표님하고 좀 알게
돼서 여기 디자이너를 좀 소개받았죠.
그래서 보시면 공간이 이렇게 현장에
조명도 이렇게 띄워서 하나의 공간처럼
편안하게 피팅할 수 있는이 텍스처도
굉장히 특이하죠.이 디자이너분이 자기
작품을 외국 그 유명한 디자인 저널에
출품을 했어요. 그 프레임이라는데
등재가 됐고 브런즈 지금 받았습니다.
가구 같은 것도 신경 써서 많이
했고요. 뿌리나무라고 해서 텍스처를
또 살려서 네. 사무실 한번 보여
드릴까요? 네.
[음악]
>> 사이즈가 작죠? 뭐 크진 않습니다.
여기는 이제 제방이고 대표실이고.
>> 네네.
>> 그리고 여기가 이제 회실.
>> 아, 원래 여기 테라스를 좀 살리면
좋았을 텐데 하다 보니까 여기가 약간
활용을 못 하게 됐어요. 구조상.
이렇게 여기 앉아 있으면 여기
서울숲도 보이고 아주 뷰가
좋더라고요.
>> 그리고 또 여기가 뻥 뚫려 있어
가지고 너무 좋은 거 같아요.
>> 또 이게 시선에 걸리는게 없죠. 어
그 이유는 저희가 건축을 할 때 다른
건물들보다 10m 인센티브를 더
받았어요.
>> 아
>> 지금 사실 옆에 건물들이 꼭대기가
25m거든요. 근데 저희는 10m를
더 받아서 거의 3층 높이를 더 받은
거죠. 그래서 이제 주변에 덜 걸리게
되어 있죠.
>> 그 높이를 받은게 이제 옆에 땅이랑
같이 지어서 그렇게 되겠죠?
>> 네. 두 필지를 공동 개발하면 10m
인센티브를 더 줍니다. 또 한 가지는
이쪽에 이제 도시 계획상 4m 도로가
계획돼 있어요. 사실 이쪽에서이
아뜰리어를 가르는 지름길이거든요.
볼목이지만 사실 여기가 뚫리면 상권이
굉장히 좋아질 수 있겠다라는 판단을
했었습니다.
>> 아 그리고 여기가 주차장이 되게 잘
돼 있어 가지고 저 항상 여기 앞에
주차하는데 너무 좋더라고요.
>> 아 제가이 토지를 또 결정했던 이유
중에 하나입니다.
>> 아 그래요? 성수가 진짜 주차할 데가
너무 없거든요.
>> 맞아요. 맞아요.
>> 그랬는데이 부지에 350대가 생긴
거예요.
>> 네. 350대요?
>> 네. 거기에 지금 주차장을 설치하고
앞에 문화센터까지 설치를 했는데이
아파트 재개발하면서 기부채남으로 아마
이거를 설계를 했다 그러더라고요.
저희 건축 스토리 중에도 하난데 원래
저희가 의무 대수가 주차가 여섯
대였어요. 그랬는데 통동구는 기부를
하면 주차를 뺄 수가 있습니다.
>> 그래서 그 1층 공간을 다 상가로
바꿨습니다. 기부 제작을 해서 그래서
좀 더 수익성을 좀 만들려고 그
설계를 했습니다.
>> 그러니까 보통 이제 여섯대 빼면
1층이 다 죽거든요. 맞습니다. 네.
그래서 지금 아까 올라올 때 보니까
1층도 다 살아 있고 그거에 대한
메리트도 확실히 있는 거 같네요.
>> 그리 이게 되게 영롱사키라 그러죠.
>> 그래서 되게이 빗 들어올 때이 느낌이
되게 좋은 거 같아요.
>> 굉장히 은은하고 통풍도 잘 돼서 물론
겨울에는 비나 뭐 눈 같은게 좀
들어올 수 있겠지만 계절감을 느끼기
또 좋은 부정인 거 같아요. 네.
>> 음.
아, 여기 뷰가 너무 좋네요.
>> 이쪽 창 뷰가 굉장히 좋아서 들어오신
분들이 되게 만족도가 좋습니다.
그니까 여기 층고는 한 몇 정도
돼요? 제일 낮은 층들이 3.7m
되고요. 1층이나 지하 뭐 같은
층들은 5.4m까지 나옵니다.
인센티브 10m을 받은 걸 신고를
높이는데 활용했기 때문에 굉장히
쾌적하고요. 바닥은 30평이지만
실제로 오시는 분들은 더 크게
느끼시거든요. 그런 부분에서 굉장히
장점이라고 생각합니다. 창이 진짜 잘
나 있어 가지고 그렇게 큰 면적은
아닌데 그런데도 불구하고 진짜 커
보이는 거 같아요.
>> 맞습니다. 사실 처음에 설계상은 여기
다 테라스를 넣고 싶었는데 용적률이
빠지더라고요. 아어했죠.
그리고 저희 건축할 때는 열교환기가
의무항이었어요. 최근에 또 이게
없어졌다 그러더라고요.
>> 아
>> 이것 때문에 배관이 너무 좀 지접을
했는데 근데 공기 순환은 굉장히
도움이 될 겁니다.
>> 네. 여기 있는 탕비실이죠. 원래
화장실이 남자, 여자 이렇게 있었는데
이쪽이 뚫려 있었거든요. 화장실
출입구에 이렇게 있는게 활용도가 너무
떨어질 것 같더라요. 그래서 급하게
양쪽으로 제가 바꾸고 이쪽을 이제
탕비실로 해 달라고 설교 변경 했는데
마지막에 견적 폭탄을 받았어요.
>> 아,
>> 근데 진짜 그렇게 비용 감안하더라도
이렇게 나눠 놓은 건 진짜 잘하신 거
같아.
>> 네. 들어오시는 분들이 여기다가
출입을 설치하면 이게 외부 화장실이
돼요.
>> 아,
>> 여기는 어차피 방화문이니까 개방을 해
놓고
>> 여기다 이제 출입구를 설계하면
되거든요. 설치하면. 그렇게 해서
이제 외부 화장실처럼 쓰면 소음에도
또 좀 자유라지고 좀 편하게 쓸 수가
있죠. 제가 딴 거는 신경 안 썼는데
이게 화장실 도기만 좀 신경
썼습니다. 아 진짜 잘하셨어요.
>> 네.
>> 와 친구 진짜 너무 높은데요.
>> 이게 높이가 5.3m 정도 됩니다.요
>> 근래에 본 건물 중에 1층 친구가
이렇게 높은 거는 처음 봤어요.
>> 네. 사실이 정도면 예전에 복층으로도
많이 썼죠.
>> 진짜 친구 높은게 깡패네요.
>> 지하도 보실까요?
>> 예예.
와, 여기도 진짜 친구 높네요.
>> 여기도 5.3m 청거고요. 여기 선큰
구조로 되어 있고 또 천장이 있어서이
공기 순환이 잘 될 수 있는
>> 네. 구조입니다.
>> 이게 이고가 큰 거 같아. 선콘
구조가 지하인데도 불구하고 되게
쾌적한 거 같습니다. 그리고 약간
민감한 질문이긴 한데 공사비가 대략
>> 주차 기부차나 이런 건 다 포함해서
45억 가까이 들었습니다. 네.
그렇게 많이든 보람이 있는 거 같긴
해요. 비용을 많이 드리긴 했지만
공간 활용을 너무 잘하신 거 같고.
네. 그리고 임차인들도 공간 활용이
잘 돼 있는 건물에 차라리 임재료 더
주어라도 좀 이렇게 들어오는 거
같아요.
>> 사실 저도 걱정이 많았는데 평소동은
확실히 그런 수요가 있는 거 같아요.
그래서 그런 부분들이 잘 맞아
떨어졌던 거 같습니다. 저
>> 요즘에 사실 임대가 잘 안 되는데
어이 건물 같은 경우에 워낙 잘
만들어 나가지고 임대가 금방 찬 거
같습니다.
>> 저도 강남에서 출근을 하지만 지나올
때마다 진짜 걱정이 많거든요. 너무
비어 있는 곳이 많아서
>> 그런 거에 비하면 정말 다행이라고
생각합니다. 사혹 매입하고 난 뒤에
이렇게 변화라든지 이런게 혹시 좀
있으세요?
>> 사실 여기 들어왔을 때 주소를 보 좀
깜방을 했어요. 서울숲 7길에
7입니다.
>> 어, 그래요?
>> 네. 주소도 되게 좋았고
>> 그래도 임차인분들도 뒤로 하시고 또
오자마자 저 20년 역사상 월매출를
최고를 찍었어요.
>> 아, 그래요?
>> 그리고 오면서 되게 좋은 일들이
많아서 어, 여기 기온이 되게
좋은가라는 느낌을 갖고 있습니다.
>> 그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 좀 찍어
봤고요. 인터뷰해 주셔서 너무
감사드리고 어, 저희 영상은 여기까지
하도록 하겠습니다. 감사합니다네.
감사합니다.
[음악]